[Musique]
pendant douze ans erika a subi des
violences de la part de son conjoint
insultes humiliations menaces de mort
devant ses filles qui grandissent dans
la peur ce jour là je sortais de ce qui
était notre logement familial et il a
tenté d'emmener avec lui les enfants
j'ai essayé de discuter avec lui mais il
m'a mis un coup de poing dans le ventre
un jeune homme qui attendaient à l'arrêt
de bus nous a vus mais à ce moment là je
ne voulais pas porter plainte car
j'étais tétanisée j'avais très peur de
lui
une peur incontrôlable qu'erica va un
jour réussir à surmonter grâce à ses
filles une nuit le père de mes filles
est venu en bas de chez moi pour ce
commentaire
il est venu me crier dessus il
m'insultait par la fenêtre
mes filles ont eu tellement peur que
l'une d'entre elle s'est mise à vomir
à cet instant là je me suis dit que je
ne pouvais pas continuer à supporter
cette situation car elle avait des
conséquences sur mes filles
ce soir là j'ai été porté plainte au
commissariat
dans les heures qui suivent sa plainte
erica est reçu au tribunal en espagne la
loi oblige la justice à instruire les
dossiers de violences conjugales dans
les 72 heures qui suivent le dépôt de
plainte
l'objectif apporter une réponse rapide
aux victimes
le juge a ensuite 15 jours pour
organiser un procès et l'état peut se
substituer à la victime carlos est l'un
des cinq juges spécialisés du tribunal
de barcelone
comment s'est passé le contact physique
entre vous deux vous me le décrire quand
je prends une ordonnance de protection
je dois décider si je mets en place une
mesure anti rapprochement de l'agresseur
vis-à-vis de la victime
l'idée c'est que la victime soit
protégée tant au niveau pénal qu'au
niveau civil
je peux envoyer l'agresseur en prison ou
lui faire porter un bracelet
électronique lui redonner un contrôle
s'il approche d'un certain périmètre à
proximité de la victime
je peux aussi décider d'une mesure de
protection 24 heures sur 24 pour la
victime depuis 2004 l'espagne s'est
dotée d'un arsenal juridique pour lutter
contre les violences conjugales au sein
du tribunal spécialisé de barcelone un
poste de soins et contigu au bureau du
juge
ici le médecin va examiner les victimes
qui porte plainte
puis c'est quand il s'agit de violences
physiques qu'il y a des éléments qui
sont faciles à détecter par n'importe
quel professionnel de la médecine comme
des blessures des bleus des conclusions
qui vont rentrer à paris et sister
et puis il y a les violences psychiques
et ce type d'agression on va l'évaluer à
travers un entretien avec les victimes
une formation spécifique est dispensée
aux professionnels pour ce juge cela est
primordial
ce n'est pas pareil vous énoncer une
tierce partie
et de dénoncer le père de ses enfants
avec lequel on vit
en quinze ans le pays a divisé par deux
le nombre de féminicide au prix d'un
vaste effort des autorités tribunaux
spécialisés formation des magistrats et
des policiers protection des victimes
200 millions d'euros sont injectés
chaque année pour lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes
devenu une grande cause nationale
schultz 63 ans est une survivante
elle se consacre aujourd'hui à une
association qui aide les femmes
pour elle ce qui a changé en espagne
c'est la prise de conscience de ce fléau
par la société toute entière selon les
nations unies la violence contre les
femmes
si le crime qui fait le plus de victimes
au monde bien plus que les crimes de
guerre où le terrorisme est donc ce qui
s'est passé à un moment donné ici en
espagne c'est qu'il a fallu nommer les
choses et mettre des mots dessus
la loi espagnole dit clairement que la
violence de genre c'est la violence qui
s'exerce par les hommes contre les
femmes
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'elles
sont des femmes
ce soir là dans les rues de barcelone
des femmes battent le pavé pour les
organisations féministes
la loi espagnole ne va pas assez loin
après la décision d'un juge qui a refusé
de qualifier de viol un fait divers
concernant une jeune fille de 15 ans
inconsciente abusée sexuellement par un
groupe d'hommes les manifestants
réclament une modification du code pénal
ils l'ont violée
même si elle ne leur a pas dit non ça
reste un viol
ce n'est pas une agression donc il faut
modifier le code pénal
j'ai 67 ans et je suis ici dans la rue
pour lutter et je continuerai à lutter
pour toutes les filles et toutes les
femmes d'espagne et du monde entier de
71 féminicide en 2003 l'espagne est
passé à 47 en 2018
trois fois moins qu'en france où l'on
compte déjà pas loin de 100 40 meurtres
de femmes par leur conjoint ou ex
conjoint depuis le début de l'année 2019